our next speaker is Donna Strickland
Donna is a Canadian experimental
physicist born in May 1959 in the City
of Guelph in southwestern Ontario she
received her bachelor's degree in
engineering physics from McMaster
University in Canada in 1981 and
obtained a PhD in optics from the
University of Rochester New York in 1999
where she and her doctoral supervisor
jajaja moo-hoo developed the technique
to immensely amplify the intensity of
short laser pulses without destroying
the amplifying medium which was a severe
limitation at the time for the
achievable laser peak power this
so-called chirp pulse amplification
technique or cpa for short
was described in a three pages long
scientific paper published in 1985 donna
was only 26 at a time and it was Donna
Strickland's first scientific
publication and a subject of her
doctoral thesis her pulse amplification
revolutionized the field of laser
science and led to new advances in many
different fields including medicine and
the much-publicized eye treatments Donna
Strickland is fascinated by lasers she
has worked at the laser division of the
Lawrence Livermore National Laboratory
and at the Princeton Advanced Technology
Center for photonics in optoelectronics
materials in 1997 she joined the physics
department of the University of Waterloo
which is currently a professor leading
an ultra-fast laser groups that develops
high-intensity laser systems for
nonlinear optics investigations she was
named a fellow of the optical Society of
America in 2008
and has chaired several of its
committees in 2013 she serves as its
president please join me in welcoming
Donna Strickland on stage to tell us
about the developments which led to this
year's Nobel Prize
[Applause]
[Music]
so thank you very much so I'm here to
tell you about how light interacts with
matter and then when the light gets very
intense it changes how it interacts with
matter I'll tell you that how we made an
intense laser and by the time we were
finished we had to rethink how intense
light interacted with matter so to start
we first have to go back and see how
does light interact with matter so
through the centuries scientists
wondered was light made up of particles
or was light made up of waves and it
went back and forth by the end of the
19th century scientists were pretty
firmly in the light is a wave category
so they were doing experiments with
different colors of light shining it on
material and watching electrons come off
the material now when they shun the red
light and I'm only going to describe
light that we see the longest wavelength
that we see with our eyes is red light
and wavelength is given by the distance
between the crests of the wave when they
Shawn red light on material electrons
did not come off when they tried to get
the light as bright as they could
electrons did not come off now when they
switch to green light which has a little
closer spacing of the crests electrons
came off but they came off with very low
speed they turned up the power of their
green light and more electrons came off
but always with very low speed and
finally when they tried violet light
which is the shortest wavelength that we
can see with our eyes so the shortest
distance between the crests the
electrons came off with higher speeds
and when they turned up the power more
electrons came off but always with those
same speeds now this flies in the face
of light being a wave if you can imagine
walking on a beach that's stony Beach
and if you just have small sea I know I
talk to a lot I don't need a mic
so when you walk on a beach and there's
stones and you just have little ripples
in the waves the stones don't even move
but if the waves are really crashing in
you will see those stones flying up the
beach and this is how waves would
usually move objects and so when we
turned up the power of the light we
certainly expected that the electrons
would fly off faster and yet they didn't
so it's this man here Albert Einstein
who probably thought of almost all of
physics all on his own what he won the
Nobel Prize for though was explaining
this effect and so we and optics are
pretty proud of the fact that this is
what he won the Nobel Prize for so what
he figured out was that light actually
is quantized in its energy there is a
minimum energy unit of light that we now
call the Photon
it's a wave-like particle so what it
says though is that the total energy in
your light is then the energy of an
individual photon multiplied by the
number of photons the other thing that
he figured out then is that each photon
has an energy given by this wavelength
and so I'm going to do an analogy
because it's harder for us to feel the
energy of light so we'll use gravity
that we all know about standing on the
earth and that if we drop the ball from
higher up it would be faster when it hit
the ground the higher up you can drop it
so now a red photon is a small photon so
we're going to imagine playing
basketball with a child size basketball
depth and so if it's a red photon
playing basketball no matter how they
try even up on their tippy toes they
cannot reach that net to drop their
electron through and no matter how many
of these childlike photons there are the
electron is never going to get through
that basketball net now if you have a
green light that's like an adults
playing with a child size basketball net
and they can actually dunk through but
only barely they're only staying
slightly taller than the basketball net
and so when they drop their ball through
ups we have to go back you can only you
have to drop your ball there you go
see so slow because it's just slightly
taller but the violet photon is like
your pro basketball player they're the
very tall good people and so they're
well above the net and when they drop
their balls through the net boom a lot
more speed but it wouldn't matter how
many of these violet photons they had
they would all be dropping at the same
speed through the net just more
electrons coming off so usually when
people study the photoelectric effect
it's about quantum mechanics but that's
not what I want you to concentrate on
what it really told us about how light
interacts with matter is that it's
always one photon meeting up with one
atom at a time and they meet with each
other and if that photon has enough
energy more than the energy that the
atom is holding on to its electron it
can then send the electron on its way
and when there's more photons coming
they interact with more atoms but always
one photon meeting one atom at a time
and that's how we understood how light
interacted with matter through the
beginning of the 20th century and then
Along Came this woman Maria gave admire
the woman who won the second the second
woman to win a Nobel Prize now I'm not
going to talk about her Nobel
prize-winning workers I know nothing
about it I'm going to tell you what she
did for her PhD in 1930 she published
the paper in 1931 and I cited that 1931
paper in my own PhD so I don't know why
she thought about this right maybe she
brought her woman's way of looking at
science and thought why don't photons
get along why don't vote on want to work
together right because if two photons
would just come into that atom at one
time they would share their energy and
two little red photons would have the
same energy as one violet photon and
then the there we go it would have an
electron come through with pretty high
speed
this is what we now call multiphoton
ionization because there's more than one
photon in the interaction she didn't get
to call it that I don't know what she
called it it was all in German um so so
now we could understand that but nobody
had seen it don't forget I Stein was
actually sitting there wondering why the
experimentalists were seeing what they
were seeing Maria gave admirer had
nobody had seen anything like this so I
don't know what made this woman think
about it but in fact nobody would see
this effect for another thirty years it
was Peter frankenz group at the
University of Michigan and I know I have
a lot of Michigan people in the audience
that were the first people to see a
multiphoton effect now they were doing
their experiment not and with atoms that
would eject electrons but what happened
was that two red photons were
momentarily absorbed by an atom and then
when the atom wanted to let that energy
go it didn't let it go as two red
photons it let it go as one photon with
twice the energy so you'll see then that
the wavelength here is half well does
that looks less than half what whatever
look all of a half can't have everything
right anyway so this is that what we
call second harmonic generation all
right and we now see it more routinely
but this was something to see in 1961 so
then it begs the question why did it
take another 30 years to see what Maria
gave admirer had predicted back in 1931
what was special about 1961 well so
we've been mentioned in the previous
talk what was special about 1961 is that
in 1960 the laser was born so because
I'm giving a Nobel lecture I do want to
honor all of the people that have won
Nobel prizes for the laser bass off
broker often towns were really honored
for developing the maser the maser came
before the laser and the M is for
microwaves rather than light in lasers
and logically it was easier to make a
maser than a laser and so that was done
in the 50s and they won a Nobel Prize
but it was the precursor to the laser
art shallow than one for laser
spectroscopy later on but he had a lot
to do with understanding how laser works
but I want to give credit to this man
Theodore Maiman working at Hughes
Aircraft he's the one who won the race
there was a race on at the end of the
50s and into 1960 who would be the
person who would first demonstrate the
laser and it's this man Ted Nieman so
1960 the laser was born and that's why
Peter Franklin's group could see this
nonlinear optical effect now why is that
regular light is shining on me very
brightly here sunlight or what have you
is like this bulb right up here and in
normal light photons of every color is
coming off that's why it looks white
they go off in all directions and they
also don't talk to each other they all
go off whenever the heck they feel like
it no cooperation whatsoever that's not
how a laser works a laser as I'm using
right here and I'm going to shine on the
wall over there you will see that the
light only goes in the one direction
where I shine it you don't see it going
over there because the light's not going
into your eyes the light's going over
there so we already have it concentrated
into one beam you'll also see that the
laser is just one color and in the case
of the laser pointer just green they
also the photons in the laser all talk
to each other and when one's out of
crest they're all at a crust and so each
of these photons are going together and
so they are making themselves to be a
giant wave and a giant wave means
there's the density of photons is
greater so let's go back and think about
the linear case here's what they saw
before 1960 just regular light photons
of every color just in case you don't
recognize them those are the photons
waving at you and because there was no
cooperation the density of the photons
is not very high so also when you may be
take a lens and you think you should put
in sunlight down to a point I'll tell
you it's not going to a point we can
only focus light down
to a wavelength so the light that we see
is about half a micron the laser eye
bildt's one micron so we're gonna go
with that one micron is a thousandth of
a millimeter and so you can't focus your
beam any smaller than that to
concentrate your photons any better than
that but the size of an atom is much
much smaller now because I'm standing in
Sweden I'm going to tell you that the
dimension of an atom is an angstrom but
we're not really supposed to use that
unit anymore I'm sorry about that my
Swedish friends we have to say that it's
1/10 of a nanometer all right so this
atom is actually 10,000 times smaller
than you can focus the light so when you
blow up that atom because of the
concentration of photons you know you're
lucky to have one atom meet one photon
there's really almost no chance of two
photons finding one atom at the very
same time but not true with a laser
light the laser light have all these
single coloured photons happily shaking
together I don't know if mine are
shaking together but they should be
shaking together and so they pack in a
lot tighter and so you have some chance
of seeing two photons in the volume of
the atom at the same time I want to
credit Nicholas Bloomberg and the person
who won the Nobel Prize for nonlinear
optics I'm also going to tell you that
it would took a long time for me to
realize there was a difference in multi
photon physics and nonlinear optics
because I was at a conference
celebrating 50 years of nonlinear optics
and I'll just tell you the people that
study molecules and atoms those are the
atomic physics types they say when they
watch in the atom that they're doing
multi photon physics those of us who
actually study light coming out we're
doing nonlinear optics but to me it was
a very subtle difference so this man
wanted for nonlinear optics so here we
go we now have a chance of two photons
so this gets me to my PhD Sherrard gave
me a paper written by Stephen Harris of
Stanford University and he had this idea
that lasers were sort of stuck in the
visible to the infrared but we might
want this wonderful type of radiation in
high-energy photons past the violet
ultraviolet maybe even out to the
extreme ultraviolet
so for that we can't just do second
harmonic or even third harmonic he had
come up with theoretically ways to maybe
have 15 photons be grabbed by one atom
and release a photon that's got 15 times
the energy
so I'll George said you know do you want
to do that just think about this paper
and see what you want to do for your PhD
so I came up with a way to maybe be in
twice ionized nickel I would be able to
absorb 9 photons so that was supposed to
be my thesis never got to it anyways
that's why I needed a high intensity
laser and so I later it self was not
going to get 9 photons squeezed in turn
atom we needed an intense laser so how
did we do it
so first I want to go back to this laser
that I have in my hand the power of this
laser is about 1 milliwatt or a
thousandth of a watt I can make it a
pulse one second long pulse by stopping
it opening it up and shutting it one
second later now in that pulse of light
then because powers energy per unit time
if my time unit is 1 second that's 1
milli Joule of energy now I can also
shine that on my hand and it doesn't
hurt at all I won't shine it in your
eyes but I'm gonna put it in my hand and
tell you that that millijoules hitting
my hand every second doesn't hurt at all
and yet my paper that was only three
pages long and got me this Nobel Prize
only had one milli Joule of energy
created it's also all the energy you
need to slice your eyeball up it's all
the energy you need to cut glass and yet
it doesn't hurt my hand at all and so
what's the difference well if I had
shown that one second pulse of light out
to where the moon is and I have no idea
where the moon is but and and I couldn't
do it anyway it would be the beginning
part of the pulse would actually be this
is always the one that for me let's go
oh there we go the front part of the
pulse would actually be 2/3 of the way
to the moon before the end of the pulse
would leave the laser
that's how fast
light travels and so now in our
one-second pulse we have one mill a
jewel of energy in this one second long
pulse of light now what did the Franken
group have in order to see that very
first multiphoton effect they had light
that was one millisecond long so that's
a thousand times shorter still 300
kilometer long line of light I will tell
you they had more than a millage oh they
had a Joule so they had a thousand times
shorter and a thousand times more energy
and then with that million fold they
were to see the odd time an atom grab
two photons at once the laser that we
built in Rochester though was shorter
than that we squeezed it down some more
and in fact we squeezed it down so that
one milli Joule of energy was in one
picosecond or just a third of a
millimeter so all of the many photons it
would have stretched two-thirds of the
way to the moon were squeezed down till
they were just a third of the millimeter
we packed those photons in so I know
that my supervisor and colleague will be
coming up here and telling you all the
amazing things this laser has done for
us I'm sure even some of them are going
to be he's going to talk about things
going on in space but I'm going to bring
us back to earth I'm gonna bring us to
Rochester New York in the United States
where I did my PhD at the Institute of
optics at the University of Rochester
and I did my research here at the
laboratory for laser energetics and
there I am back in the day now inside
this laboratory for laser energetics was
this absolutely beautiful dye laser it
was red and green and as I said it just
seemed like a Christmas tree to me and I
wanted to work with Gerard in this
wonderful group it is a dye laser a dye
laser is a type of short pulse laser in
fact this laser the pulses were actually
ten times shorter than what I'm talking
about so only a 30th of a millimeter
long so we had short laser pulses
problem is dye lasers don't like to grab
their energy and hang on to it and so
that you can't get a big energy diet
laser
so you can have short pulses but the
reason that the laboratory for laser
energetics was there was to study laser
fusion and to study laser fusion you
need a big laser and they had a big
laser this was known as the mega laser
it was 24 beams and it could produce a
kilojoule of energy not a millijoules
a kilojoule that's a million times more
energy so in the laser lab we had short
pulses and we had big energy lasers but
we couldn't put them together more than
one problem one the dye laser had red
photons and this one wants to amplify
infrared photons so they wouldn't have
spoken to each other but there was a
bigger problem when people tried to put
slightly short pulses even into these
lasers what they found was that the rod
would actually get drilled all the way
through and you were left with a very
expensive piece of glass that wasn't any
good so that did so they had a stop
trying to put short pulses down their
laser rods because these nonlinear
optical effects were happening inside
the laser rods and they were drilling
holes all the way through them so that
was the conundrum that we were in in the
early 1980s and then gerard had his
beautiful idea so there are no pictures
because I hate having my picture taken
I've had to get used to it since October
2nd but there are no pictures which are
not you together so we were out of
meeting a few years back and took this
picture so this is a very simple
beautiful idea this is what we want here
we want a lot of energy we want it in a
very short pulse we just don't want that
in our amplifier so if we don't want
that in our amplifier what can we do
just start with a short pulse strategy
to make it a long pulse amplify it up
and then about the end compress it all
the way back down and here you have what
I like to call a laser hammer
so now how did we actually do it we're
going to go back to this lab because
this was the lab by now you'll see I've
changed the title of it even though I'm
showing you the very same laser and so
the green beam is actually not a green
laser this is the laser back here it's
infrared you can't see the beam coming
out of the laser because it's infrared
and we can't see it neither can the
camera the kind of mirrors that we use
in a laser lab direct just the color we
want to direct and so this green light
bent at this mirror but the infrared
came on through it would have gone to a
beam dump to protect all of us from I
feeling the heat of that very strong
laser and so that laser how the same
wavelength as the big neodymium glass
amplifiers that we wanted to use so that
was the laser I was to use you can also
see there's simply no room in the end
for me there was one packed lab but they
shoved me into that corner where the
infrared came out and there I am in 1985
with up 1.4 kilometers of optical fiber
so why did we need this fiber well there
was one advantage of it's not why we
needed it because there was no room for
me here once we had the light going down
the fiber that fiber then went through
the air ducts down the length of the
laboratory for laser energetics where I
built the amplifier at the other end of
the building
that was one thing but two other reasons
that we needed this fiber is that the
laser the pump the dye laser was not as
short as we wanted and we needed more
colors I'm going to explain why we
needed more colors I don't have time to
tell you what nonlinear optical effect
made the colors you'll just have to
believe me that it did and then this is
the component though what we really
needed the fiber for this was our pulse
stretcher so first to understand pulse
stretching we have to know why do we
need a lot of colors in order to make a
short pulse if you watch just one of
these colors and we can just do the red
one you see it goes along there a red
wave would go on forever now if you take
more colors and you say that you want
all of them to start here you'll see
that each wavelength starts to come
apart you don't have to go very far
until some
pekes while others are troughs and so if
one waves a peak and the other waves of
trough they cancel each other out to be
nothing and so the more colors you can
add in the quicker you will get to where
it's zero and so the more colors you
have the shorter pulse you have so we
created the colors in the fibre and now
it's time to stretch it how does that
work well in the way that light
interacts with matter I said that the
red photons have the least energy when
they meet up with their atoms they sort
of shake hands but then they say we have
you know have nothing in common off you
go
so they actually run faster than the
green and by the time it's a blue photon
they're actually considering some time
do we or do we not want to interchange
your energy and it takes a little longer
for that blue one to the side now and
keep on going so now if you go down
fiber you will see that the red ran the
green walked and the blue sort of
crawled and if you go down something
like 1.4 kilometers of fiber well the
red ran the green and now you have a
long pulse so I want to explain the name
of chirped pulse amplification a birds
chirp it's called a chirp because the
sound frequency changes in time through
the note that he's making so you'll see
that in the way to get a long pulse is
to have the red frequencies out first
and then the green and then the blue so
through our laser pulse now the
frequency changes and that's called a
chirp it's called chirp pulse
amplification because this is an hour
stretched pulse that we want to amplify
up so how does the amplification work so
it's it's some material that has some
atoms and sitting there not doing
anything they have to be excited by some
kind of energy source the original
lasers and the laser that I used you
just use flash lamps you'll see that it
lights up most not all most of the atoms
and a good storage medium will hang on
to that energy and stay excited until a
photon decides to come by so then you
can have a photon come along and meet up
with an atom and because we've excited
these atoms so they have the very same
energy as the photon that we're going to
try to amplify they meet each other
the photon says to the atom I'll take
your energy with me and now we have two
photons and that atom lost its energy
those two photons are marching and step
together and they meet two more atoms
and now we have four photons and we've
given up two atoms of energy and by the
end we'll have eight photons and they've
given up the out four more atoms of
energy now this is actually very
wasteful because you'll see that by the
end of it we've left most of the energy
there in the amplifier so that's a
complete waste and we don't want to do
that if it was a laser we were putting
mirrors on either end and have it go
back and forth until we steal all of
that energy and this is then why we have
to keep building huge lasers if we want
a lot of energy the laser rod itself
determines the energy per unit area that
you can take and if you want to grab it
all you actually have to put in almost
that much energy to start to snowplow
through and take the energy so each
amplification gets a certain energy per
unit area if you want more energy you
must get make your beam bigger you must
make your amplifier bigger and you plow
through again the other thing I want to
point out that is that the laser
material decides what's the energy per
unit area but the nonlinear things that
can cause damage is the energy per unit
volume so once you know what laser
you're using that determines how much
you must stretch the pulse so that you
keep it below any kind of damage
threshold so that's why we would have to
chirp based on the type of laser that we
used so now that we're amplified up it's
just time to compress and so with a pair
of parallel gratings greetings are act
like prisms that send different colors
of light out to different angles and so
if you watch the path and you'll see the
red because it was stretched it's
further ahead than the green and the
blue is trailing that when it comes off
this grate and in each goes and their
own angles the by the time the blue one
has managed to get to the grading the
red one had to travel all the way back
here and could get here so that when
they all leave the second grading
they're all going together and we've put
all of the photons back
to gather in time and so we have a short
pulse so then it was just time to
measure it my colleague Steve Williamson
came into my lab with history camera one
night and together we measured did I or
did I not actually have an intense short
pulse and the answer was yes so we were
very happy that night in 1985 so what
did we do with it well remember I wanted
to study well I want to study harmonic
generation that proved too difficult so
we're going to go back to the idea of
multiphoton ionization and we thought
that we would just kick that electron
and give it so much energy that it would
be able to come out of this well that it
sits in in the atom and so all those
photons would come up and kick that
electron out that's what we were
expecting to see but that's not what we
saw we have made such an intense laser
that the photons were packed in there so
tight we no longer had to worry about
them being photons it was back to being
just one giant wave now although it's a
short pulse wave so each crest gets a
little bit more intense and a little bit
more intense and so what happens when
you have a giant wave is that it
interacts with the atom that was sitting
in its potential my head can be the
electron and it would the wave would
push it this way and then the wave would
push it that way and then it pushed it
more and it pushed it more and finally
pushed it so much that electron was
allowed to go out of the wealth but not
only does it go out of the well it goes
out of the well into this giant electric
force and it is like a cannon being shot
right out of there now can either leave
or in two femtoseconds that lights to
own back and it may be driven right back
to the ionic core it just depends and
I'm not here to tell you about what
happens
oops let me show you did I show you at
least the electron right now no there
you go the electron at least went out
I'm gonna leave that to my PhD
supervisor colleague and friend Gerard
mermoo to tell you about what we
understand now about the new standing
intense laser light interacting with
atoms and I will just thank all the
people I want to thank the people that
built the orig
cpa with me of course yard but also
steve williamson and Marcel Bouvier who
are here with me today
Gerard likes to tell people how I said
that CPA would not be a good PhD project
or thesis could not be my PhD thesis I
don't know why he tells the story
because I was right
it could not be I had to do science with
it which I did multiphoton ionization
and I want to thank the gentleman that
helped me with that project as well and
finally I would like to thank the
creative team at the University of
Waterloo for making these wonderful
slides for me thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you